wie geht es eigentlich den
prominentesten patienten der welt super
geht's den donald trump hat nach eigenen
angaben beziehungsweise
wahnvorstellungen corona nicht nur
überstanden was kann ja jeder sondern
regelrecht bezwungen ja fertig gemacht
das virus hatte keine chance gegen den
mann
trump schreibt sich selbst gesund und
seitdem folgt leider videobotschaft auf
videobotschaft tenor keine angst vor
corona ist nun grippe lebt euer leben
weiter mir gehts bombe ja genau
nur eine fußnote aber inzwischen
schminken sie ihn wirklich wie rex gildo
im endstadium ist orange facing
eigentlich noch erlaubt ja gut tatsache
ist oft werden menschen wissen sie durch
krankheiten geläutert fast demütig hat
in dem konkreten fall leider so nicht
geklappt beim commander-in-chief meiner
jetzt mal ganz ernsthaft wie kann man
den amerikanern zu rufen keine angst vor
corona geht alle raus wenn über 210.000
von denen schon gestorben sind
david hat offensichtlich die letzten
kümmerlichen reste von empathie aus
seiner überaus gespült dabei ist der
präsident doch eindeutig risikopatient
oder weniger charmant formuliert trump
gehört zur risikogruppe wegen seines
alters und weil er nicht nur
übergewichtig sondern fettleibig ist
also unverschämtheit der hat lediglich
schwere haare tram glaubt wirklich gott
persönlich hat ihn gerettet
ja oder war es doch die noch gar nicht
zugelassene antikörpertherapie aber
fürchtet euch nicht lieber amis weil
trump ja selber so eine art gnädiger
gott ist hat sich für euch alle was
ausgedacht
vor allem für die besonders gefährdeten
senioren die sind doch besonders
gefährdet oder
the same thing you get free no church
die great ist das denn alle amerikaner
bekommen seine behandlung
die werden also alle per hubschrauber
ins beste krankenhaus geflogen und
kriegen die neuesten medikamente umsonst
gut in dem was wir normalen
erdenbewohner die realität nennen will
schramms regierung obama kehrt total
zurück fahren wodurch demnächst wohl
weitere 20 millionen amerikaner ganz
ohne krankenversicherung da steht aber
auch das ist umsonst no charge donald
trump hat inzwischen das halbe weiße
haus angesteckt so eine bio waffe auf
zwei beinen
vor allem die vorstellung seiner neuen
supreme court richterin im sogenannten
rosengarten natürlich ohne masken und
mit ganz viel umarmung ist ja klar war
ein echtes super special event hier
jetzt nicht im heute-show fanshop jetzt
neu super marios bruder das coole tromp
endspiel versuch als präsident im
rosengarten so viele gäste wie möglich
mit corona anzustecken einfach drauf
springen und erlösten aber nicht die
putzfrau mobile office vergessen
super spread bis zum nervenzerfetzenden
finale da verfolgst du den endgegner joe
biden super-mario spread nur für
nintendo virus h
dies wegen weigert sich jump also
nächste woche bei einem rein virtuellen
duell mit joe biden mitzumachen weil er
da keinen anstecken kann ist unglaublich
es ist wirklich nicht zu fassen monate
lang redet dieser präsident das virus
klein und jetzt versucht er daraus eine
heldengeschichte zu stricken
trump ist in allen der beste sogar im
krank sein sagt seine sprecherin
er hat erfahrung ex-präsident erfahrung
als business mann hat erfahrung als
corona erkrankter der beiden musen von
120 usa beiden der alte feiglingen läuft
immer mit maske um das hat er jetzt
davon gar keine krone erfahrung ja trump
krieg steroide
ich bin jetzt wirklich kein arzt nur als
frage ist es wirklich schlau ein mann
der sich
seit geburt für den allergrößten hält
und auch steroide zu geben
nebenwirkungen sind da im krankenhaus
hat er in wenigen minuten 18 tweets
rausgehauen und zwar alle in
großbuchstaben sowas wie law and order
oder schwarztee vanilla cherry woods
space fonds seine mitarbeiter haben ihn
dann gewaltsam gestoppt bei 1 putins
beach boat junge junge
eine echt verrückte woche selbst nach
[Musik]
den eilig mit winkel
apropos goodnight nur drei nächte war
der präsident insgesamt im sogenannten
wall street krankenhaus als aktiver
corona fall kann man drei nächte da
fällt mir ein was hat die ama melania
eigentlich in der zeit gemacht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja macht sinn
schramms umgang mit seiner corona
infektion müsste ihnen doch endgültig
den wahlsieg osten sollte man denken
jetzt die schlechte nachricht vor genau
vier jahren nach greppin beide posieren
an sich haben wir exakt dasselbe gedacht
und dann hat er trotzdem gewonnen
warum weil die wahren probleme der usa
viel tiefer gehen höchste zeit für eine
intervention unter freunden mit
christian ehring
[Musik]
[Applaus]
justin seinen job in amerika setz dich
mal hin wir müssen reden
ich weiß es ist total peinlich wenn der
ausgerechnet die deutschen demokratie
erklären
ihr habt uns demokratie damals
beigebracht mit schokolade und
waffengewalt danke nochmal aber gerade
weil wir so viel von euch gelernt haben
amerikaner fallen uns jetzt halt sachen
auf westfalen und sachen auf zum
beispiel dass zwei eurer letzten drei
präsidenten bush und trump gewonnen
haben obwohl sie weniger stimmen hatten
die schwaben sogar drei millionen nummer
als idee jetzt noch mal quer gedacht
könnte man nicht einfach die stimmen
also wir deutschen nennen das zählen
zählen
und wer hat der hat gewonnen da ist
klingt crazy neuer electoral college das
ist völlig behämmert die partei die bei
euch nur eine stimme mehr holt in einem
bundesstaat kriegt sämtliche sogenannte
wahlmänner und die schickt man dann nach
washington hier sind original bilder von
der letzten wahl 2016
das hat vor 200 jahren bestimmt total
sinn gemacht aber heute ohne die ganzen
komantschen überfälle und mit internet
ja so wie das bei euch läuft hat zwar
beiden in umfragen aktuell 16 prozent
vorsprung aber dass es letztlich
leider wer war das euer präsident will
nicht mal die friedliche machtübergabe
garantieren im fall einer niederlage
kann sagt sogar lukaschenko in
weißrussland alter das kannst du so
nicht bringen
trumps partei tut alles um potenzielle
demokraten fans am wählen zu hindern
weil besonders angehörige von
minderheiten in großstädten vom early
voting gebrauch machen hat zum beispiel
texas die zahl der wahllokale für frühe
stimmabgaben jetzt auf eine station po
landkreis beschränkt heißt wer trotzdem
hin will muss ewig anstehen er hier über
sieben stunden in solchen schlangen
werden vor langeweile kinder gezeugt und
geboren
ja und das hat methode seit 2012 haben
von republikanern regierte staaten über
1600 wahllokale geschlossen
es werden auch immer wieder leute
einfach aus wählerlisten rausgestrichen
oder wieder nach hause geschickt weil
sie nicht den gerade passenden
lichtbildausweis dabei haben wie hier in
texas aber der studentenausweis der
universität von texas einer staatlichen
uni zum beispiel zählt nicht die waffen
registrierungs karte aber schon klar in
texas kannst du sogar ein kreuzchen mit
der 45er machen
wie gesagt gilt uns alles nichts an und
ich danke für die rosinenbomber aber es
ist völlig klar was passieren wird bei
euch trump erklärt sich am wahlabend zum
sieger und den rest regelt der supreme
court das höchste gericht wie 2000 bei
bush als florida nicht mehr zu ende
zählen durfte
womit wir jetzt um himmels willen nicht
sagen wollen dass ein autokrat und
saunagäste präsident wenn jemand der
präsident der vereinigten staaten ist
dann ist seine autorität total so wird
es sein total total das wissen die
gouverneure schade ist doch ein
autograph jetzt mal seriously liebe amis
ihr müsst da etwas ändern
ihr müsst was ändert ich meine auch dass
jeder bundesstaat zwei senatoren
entsendet egal wie viele leute in der
stadt wohnen sogar kalifornien dabei
haben die genauso viele einwohner wie 15
staaten im konservativen beide welt
zusammen das geht nicht so wie das
gericht es geht es geht nicht
leute regierungen müssen irgendwie
mehrheitsverhältnisse widerspiegeln was
ihr da macht das ist so als ob in
deutschland weiß ich nicht sagen wir mal
der vorsitzende einer regionalen
splitterpartei am ende bundeskanzler
schlechtes beispiel christian ehring
alter der kleb hatte er wieder alles
wahnsinn
inhaltlich stark satire comedy gold ich
habe es noch drauf also ich würde den
kanal direkt abonnieren und auf gefällt
mir drücken wenn ich das nicht so getan
hätte das war wirklich stark
[Musik]